[Music]
yeah yeah
and we're going to turn up on this one
dj bullet cavs let's get it
do it for the city look i'm with the
[ __ ] affiliated with a different [ __ ]
don't compare me to these other rappers
they [ __ ] with me i'm chipping [ __ ]
i ain't doing no stupid [ __ ] you hard
now you a super [ __ ]
last year you was turned down lying said
you were shooting [ __ ] but anyway i got
a mini k
i'm from l.a i'll be in the bay i'm the
same [ __ ] on any day
i'm all in you just in the way county
jail took many phases
shake down see many rays race rise gain
violence they ask what happened you
remain solid
look i don't trust none of these [ __ ]
i don't trust none of these [ __ ]
some [ __ ] act like they with you some
[ __ ] get mad try to chip you
i roll backs [ __ ] swishers watching
dirty money like dishes
diamonds wet they fishes goons on deck
day vicious can't stop and i won't stop
clip hanging think i won't pop [ __ ] this
rap [ __ ] i really sold rocks out of dope
spots hold the whole block up
pull up with a chrome chopper high ball
chairs whole block up hit em up no time
to ask who shot you stole
[Music]
show you how to break it more proper
show you how to rock the soft powder my
flow
sick [ __ ] call the doctor marathon i
met all the pop-ups used to be behind
them all locked up
now i tear down i'm all a shop up i just
want a ball and get my guap up
my brother died to the streets my mama
died by the police
that's why i slide if his beef got sick
and tired of point o
e he couldn't even leave no seed cause
he died at 15
my mama died when she was 25 i pray to
god it's a bad dream then i got shot i'm
a living legend with the paramedics the
hell of heaven
i don't even know where i'm headed but
they told me keep it come aesthetic but
anyway
i got a mini k i'm from l.a i'll be in
the ay this ain't [ __ ] on any day
i'm all in use it in the way camp
drivers caught minnie face
shake down seen plenty raised can't wait
time really paid
imma get my own billy made but saki's
own no finishes i get paid just to hit
the stage school i ain't get to walk the
stage
never got a chance to graduate i'm not a
hater i congratulate
why these jealous [ __ ] have to hate
jealous [ __ ] you ain't having cake
you say you real but you're hella fake i
come from where they see yellow tape
economy boosting the crime rate [ __ ]
be boosting the murder right
[ __ ] in jail cause crime pays yeah
[Music]
west west west west album coming out it
might be out now [ __ ] december 23rd
[ __ ] go get that
definition of pain yeah